kinder wie die Zeit vergeht genau
gestern vor einem Jahr wurden Olaf
Scholz und sein Kabinett vereidigt ein
Jahr Ampel sie wissen es ja noch
gestartet als Koalition des Fortschritts
der Modernisierung der tollen
gemeinsamen Ideen jetzt sind es vor
allem gemeinsame Schulden ja ein Wumms
jagt den nächsten es geht nur noch ums
Geld oder kann man ihn doch zurückholen
den Zauber der jedem Anfang innewohnt
diese Woche zum Jahrestag hat der Olaf
wenigstens mal versucht der Kanzler hat
es auch nicht immer einfach
wenn es darum geht sich in der Ampel
durchzusetzen
ich hätte eher gedacht sie gönnen sich
eine Tafel Ritter Sport herbe
Enttäuschung so kann man sich Ehrenmann
fakt ist noch nie musste eine
Bundesregierung mit so vielen Krisen
gleichzeitig schon hier Ukraine Energie
Inflation ist doch logisch das ist ein
oder andere Lieblingsprojekt der
Parteien auf der Strecke bleibt manchmal
sind wir in unserem Urteil vielleicht
auch zu gnadenlos im Grunde wie in der
Schule sie haben gesagt sie geben der
Ampel die Note 3+ eine glatte Note 4
also ich würde uns eine zwei geben
Schulnote 4,1
befriedigen geben ich würde der Ampel im
Moment eine 4 minus geben und sie
ausdrücklich als versetzungsgefährdet
betrachten wo muss die Koalition denn
Nachsitzen um mindestens sagen wir mal
auf zwei plus zu kommen tja da fragen
Sie mich was
oh Gott wenn die sitzen bleiben müssen
wir dann alle zusammen das letzte Jahr
wiederholen oh nein
hier diese Woche im Spiegel Mehrheit der
Deutschen mit allen Ministern
unzufrieden wie geht das denn da sind
welche dabei die kennt keine Sau oder
wissen Sie wer Bettina stark Watzinger
ist kennen sie gar nicht ne kein Wunder
das ist nämlich gar nicht mit Tina stark
war singer das ist Bettina stark
bazinger unsere Familienministerin ist
sie auch nicht dieses Bildungsministerin
nichts davon habt ihr gewusst aber seid
unzufrieden mit der Frau was ist denn
los mit euch
und tatsächlich hat die Ampel ja mehr
gemacht als nur Schulden da war doch
mehr gut war zum Beispiel das 9 € Ticket
genau wie die mindestlohnerhöhung die
überfällige wenn ich der Regierung ein
unverbindlichen Tipp für die Zukunft
geben dürfte nicht ohne Not Sachen
versprechen die man eh nicht halten kann
Stichwort zwei Prozent für Verteidigung
oder 4 tausend neue Wohnungen jedes Jahr
hatte diese Frau hier angekündigt das
erste Mal seit vielen Jahren gibt es
wieder ein eigenständiges Ministerium
für Bauen und Wohnen mir ist das wichtig
für viele Menschen ist ihre Wohnung auch
ihr zu Hause
ach so
man wohnt bei sich zu Hause
wussten sie dass meine Damen und Herren
ja vielen vielen Dank Bettina stark
Watzinger ah nee das war jetzt klarer
geil Witz unsere bauministerin der haben
alle Experten seit Monaten
gebetsmühlenartig gesagt Clara 400.000
Wohnungen pro Jahr sind nicht zu
schaffen nicht zu schaffen ja wegen
Materialkosten Bauzinsen you name it
geht nicht aber die Ampel antwortet
trotzig wir verfolgen das Ziel dennoch
weiter ja ich verfolge auch weiter Hosen
Größe 34
wird aber nie passieren
tatsächlich werden es in diesem Jahr
wohl nur rund 250.000 Wohnungen sie sind
krachend gescheitert mit ihrem Ziel im
nächsten Jahr werden es wahrscheinlich
noch weniger Wohnung und angesichts
dieser vielen Hiobsbotschaften und mit
Blick auch auf die Jahreszeit könnte
einem meiner Maria Rilkes Gedicht
Herbsttag in den Sinn kommen Rilke
schreibt wer jetzt kein Haus hat baut
keines mehr
richtig im Herbst und Winter kein Haus
haben ist besonders ärgerlich worauf
klaritz ihrer Kollegin pfiffig entgegnet
das tröstliche ist ja beim Herbst dass
man weiß der nächste Frühling der kommt
von ganz alleine
das Klärchen kurze Korrektur ja der
Frühling kommt von ganz alleine wohnen
leider nicht die muss man bauen also
liebe Ampel mein Geburtstagswunsch wäre
weniger versprechen und vielleicht noch
ein bisschen weniger Zoff untereinander
dann geht's bergauf auch mit den
Umfragen übrigens jetzt nicht im heute
show Fanshop ganz tolle Sache das
offizielle Ampel Fotobuch zum ersten
Jahr unter anderem mit Bildern von Olaf
Scholz die ja die die ganze Bandbreite
seiner Emotionen in den letzten Monaten
zeigen von weil sie nicht was hatten
alles Begeisterung über
Entsetzen bis zu nackter Wut hier Frau
geibitz wie sie die 400.000 Wohnungen
einweit dann ein Foto von Robert habecks
Opa warte mal das ist Robert Habeck
brutal gealtert in dem Jahr und die
vielleicht größte Überraschung meine
Damen und Herren Kevin Kühnert ist in
der Ampel plötzlich zum Mann gereift
[Applaus]
ja
herzlichen Glückwunsch
gut den hat er sich für einen guten
Zweck wachsen lassen den pornobalken
aber
neun Haare reichen halt nicht ich weiß
wovon ich rede ernsthaft ernsthaft
gerade in dieser Woche liebe Zuschauer
sollten wir dankbar sein dass wir die
Ampel haben also eine demokratisch
gewählte Regierung sie haben es
natürlich mitgekriegt beinahe hätten
sich hier durchgeknallte Reichsbürger an
die Macht geputzt das war relativ knapp
über 3000 Polizisten haben mit einer
Razzia ein Netzwerk aus reichsbürgern
q-annengläubigen und sonstigen
Flitzpiepen ausgehoben angeführt von
keinem geringeren als Prinz Heinrich dem
13 zu Reus wer ist das Heinrich der 13
Prinz Reus der 71-Jährige Unternehmer
aus Frankfurt am Main soll auch versucht
haben Kontakt nach Russland aufzunehmen
in Moskau heißt es man wissen von nichts
Alter wenn du sogar den Russen zu irre
bist das ist
das ist kein gutes Zeichen ja Prinz
Heini der Viertel vor zwölfte hat sogar
schon ein richtiges Schattenkabinett
gebildet mit einer ehemaligen
afd-abgeordneten als Justizministerin
leider das ist die eher schlechte
Nachricht sind auch ein aktiver ksk-mann
und mehrere Bundeswehr Veteranen dabei
also Leute mit militärische Erfahrung
und mit Zugang zu Waffen das ist
brandgefährlich unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden müssen sich
vielleicht doch noch mal genauer
angucken wer so alles für Sie arbeitet
wer hat noch mit geputzt beispielsweise
hatte diese Schattenregierung über die
man nachgedacht hat die hatte wohl zwei
sehr also Menschen die man für okkulte
Handlungen irgendwie zur Beratung
hinzugezogen hat ja die hatten zwei sehr
und keiner hat die Razzia kommen sehen
die würde ich aber direkt feuern muss
ich sagen ja rund 21.000 Reichsbürger
Leben wohl in Deutschland mitten unter
uns Menschen die sagen die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland die gibt es
gar nicht weswegen sie sich zum Beispiel
eigene Führerscheine ausstellen ja wir
haben eigene Führerscheine sind das
Spinner vielleicht aber eben zum Teil
bewaffnete Spinner die wollen keine
Demokratie die wollen Fürsten Könige
blaublütige Führer wir erleben also
gerade sowas wie die ja wie die
Wiedergeburt des deutschen Adels egal wo
du reinsetzt bei Phoenix sehe ich die
gesichtskirmes von Beatrix von Storch
bei der Sesamstraße reduziert der doofe
Herr von Bödefeld
hier Peter von Froster Annette der ist
gar nicht adelig im Gegensatz zu ihm
hier
ach ja Adlige sie haben einfach den
besseren Genpool als wir dank tausend
Jahre die eigene Cousine heiraten aber
mal zurück zu Prinz Heinrich unserem
Regenten der Herzen sein Sprecher gibt
genau in diesen Minuten eine
Pressekonferenz im
familien-jagdschloss Waidmannsheil in
Bad Lobenstein Thüringen ich würde sagen
wir hören mal live rein ja meine Damen
und Herren von der Weltpresse schön dass
sie so zahlreich zu zweit erschienen
sind ich darf Ihnen herzliche Grüße von
Prinz Heinrich aus der U-Haft ausrichten
ihre Durchlaucht hält sich tapfer im
Kerker der Deutschland GmbH aber was ihm
da wieder fährt ist natürlich ein
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
sitzt da zusammen mit
bürgerlich
heute hat ihm einen Gefängniswärter wohl
tatsächlich seinen nachmittags Cherry
verweigert
verzeiung geht mir doch sehr nah gibt es
Fragen Ihrerseits ja hier Oliver Welke
ZDF Lügen Funk
was was sind denn jetzt die weiteren
Pläne des Terror Prinzen an denen hat
sich nichts geändert ihre Majestät
bittet das deutsche Volk ausdrücklich
Ruhe zu bewahren er bleibt natürlich
unser einziges legitimes Staatsoberhaupt
für das Schloss Bellevue läuft bereits
eine Räumungsklage gegen den motorischen
Mietnomaden Frank Walter Steinmeier
der Prinz hat völlig recht das Ende der
Monarchie 1918 war unser allergrößtes
Unglück everything bis dahin war alles
in Ordnung und Fürstentum Reus und die
Menschen lebten ein glückliches Leben
lief etwas nicht rund ging man zum
Prinzen wohin gehen sie heute zu ihrem
Parlamentarier Landesebene Bundesebene
EU-Ebene viel Glück ja viel Glück alles
war besser da gab es auch noch das Recht
der ersten Nacht bei jedem frisch
verheirateten Paar durfte der Prinz als
erster drüber und zwar über beide
es war nicht alles schlecht im
Mittelalter
und der Prinz Heinrich gelten außerdem
wieder die Grenzen von 1871 ich fordere
die Franzosen hiermit auf Elsass
Lothringen friedlich zurückzugeben ja
ihr Chef hat viele frische Ideen seine
eigene Familie also das Haus Reust
bezeichnet ihn trotzdem als und ich
zitiere verwirrten alten Mann
dagegen haben wir offiziell Klage
eingereicht der Prinz ist nicht alt
und wie genau wollten sie mit gerade mal
50 verschwören einen Umsturz
organisieren und unser Parlament
besetzen ich bitte Sie den ollen
Reichstag stürmen das geht im Notfall
auch alleine wenn man nur entschlossen
genug ist
der Bundestag ich gehe da jetzt hoch wir
können mitkommen oder auch nicht
ihr könnt weiter das System aufrecht
wirken lassen ich gehe jetzt da hoch und
das setze den Bundestag das ist was was
wir alle machen kann
[Musik]
das war übrigens der Sohn des Prinzen
Heinrich IV zu Reus der ist in unserem
Kabinett als Bildungsminister vorgesehen
nein alles läuft nach Plan ist es gibt
nur ein Problem die deutsche
reichsbürgerszene ist leider sehr
zersplittert hier laufen unzählige
Fürsten und Könige rum also alles irre
wenn Sie mich fragen schaffen wir freien
Männer und Frauen gemäß unserem freien
Willen heute hier und in diesem
geschichtlichen Augenblick einen neuen
deutschen Staat
vielzüglich lässt sich zum obersten
souverän grünen eigentlich ist der
gelernter Koch jetzt ist der Peter der
Große meine Betätigung die ist
Reichskanzler der ex-regierung Deutsche
Reich und ich bin auch noch
Prinz von Hannover und Prinz vom Haus
Winter
[Gelächter]
ist ja lächerlich man kann sich doch
nicht einfach zum König oder Kanzler
ernennen also Heinrich kann das
natürlich aber die anderen doch nicht
das ist ja hier nur noch Chaos auf die
Knie ihr Pöpel
ich bin der neue Kaiser von Thüringen
Klaus-dieter der dritte
und ihr seid alle verhaftet Papa
papa du hast aber nicht schon wieder den
Medikamente abgesetzt oder geh bitte auf
dein Zimmer darauf steht die Todesstrafe
Papa leg den Säbel Weg Albrecht Humboldt
meine Damen und Herren vielen Dank
[Applaus]
so
ganz andere Frage wissen Sie eigentlich
schon was sie ihrem Partner diesmal zu
Weihnachten schenken ich schon in jedem
Fall was klimaneutrales ja gerade in der
Adventszeit werde ich immer so
sentimental und sage mir komm mach auch
mal was für den Planeten du alte
Umweltsau und dann buche ich meine
Urlaubsflüge ja
aber natürlich mit CO2 Kompensation das
wissen viele gar nicht man kann ja
fliegen ohne dass es irgendwas mit dem
Klima macht das voll praktisch ja kostet
nur eine Handvoll Kröten und die gehen
dann dann irgendwelche Projekte die
irgendwas machen also im Detail weiß ich
das auch nicht das müsste vielleicht mal
so eine EU-Studie klären die
Wissenschaftler haben mehr als 5000
Projekte untersucht acht von zehn sparen
offenbar kein CO2 ein ja Moment nur zwei
von zehn war ein gut klingt wenig aber
ich sag mal wenn zwei von zehn gut
gewesen wären hätten wir gegen Japan
gewonnen denken sie da mal drüber nach
guck mal an viele
co2-kompensationsprojekte sind also eher
Greenwashing gut zu wissen ergeben man
Beispiel der Flughafen München Zahl 2,5
Millionen Euro an einen privaten
Waldbesitzer damit der seinen Wald
entstand hält und im Gegenzug nennt er
den dann klimawalz ja CO2 spart das
jetzt nicht direkt aber die Geste zählt
oder nehmen wir mal Aldi wenn sie da
Milch kaufen ist bei der Herstellung
natürlich CO2 entstanden geht nicht
anders so wird aber ausgeglichen in dem
Aldi unter anderem hier in Uruguay Bäume
pflanzt die CO2 binden sieht super aus
allerdings wird gepflanzt wo vorher
abgeholzt wurde wir zahlen also als
milchkäufer irgendwelchen Waldbesitzern
die Aufforstung die sie sowieso egal ist
ein geniales Konzept ist wirklich genial
verstehen sie je mehr Bäume gefällt
werden desto mehr kann man wieder
anpflanzen
ja ja natürlich
habe ich verschlungen als Kind natürlich
gibt es auch Projekte die dem Klima
helfen zum Beispiel wenn in
afrikanischen Ländern in denen
vorwiegend mit Holz gekocht wird
effizientere Öfen finanziert werden oder
wenn tatsächlich Ackerflächen aufgekauft
werden um da Bäume drauf zu pflanzen
meine da kann man nichts gegen sagen
oder wir maßen uns an unseren Fußdruck
außerhalb Deutschlands außerhalb Europas
nochmal zu vergrößern indem wir Land
woanders beanspruchen in uns sagen ihr
dürft da jetzt nicht mehr
Emissionen produzieren weil die wollen
wir und wir haben dafür bezahlt
natürlich sollen die im globalen Süden
für uns Emissionen sparen andersrum
macht ja keinen Spaß ja es kann halt
nicht jeder so leben wie wir sorry
vielleicht und ich weiß das ist jetzt
ein furchtbarer Gedanke aber vielleicht
geht Klimaschutz doch nicht ganz ohne
Verzicht allein das Wort dann doch
lieber kompensieren
jetzt sofort runterladen applass die App
für den modernen Ablasshandel hier
kannst du alles kompensieren mal wieder
grundlos jemanden zusammengeschlagen
Spende einfach mit einem Klick zwei Euro
an den Malteser Hilfsdienst zu filzchips
gefressen macht nix für 299 geht
irgendwo auf der Welt einer für dich ins
Fitnessstudio und jetzt neu nachhaltige
Prostitution für gerade mal 30 € extra
engagiert sich der Zuhälter gegen die
Ausbeutung von Sexarbeiterinnen aus
Osteuropa applass die Flatrate fürs gute
Gewissen
[Applaus]
der der letzte Gag war sexistisch das
ist aber nicht schlimm das gleiche kurz
mal aus mit 50 Cent an eine
feministische poetry slammerin in Berlin
so kompensiert
Teil des Problems Begriffe wie
nachhaltig oder klimaneutral sind gar
nicht geschützt und dann stellt sich zum
Beispiel raus dass das tolle nachhaltige
deutsche adidas Trikot aus angeblich 50%
Ocean Plastik gar nicht zu 50% Ocean ist
hier übrigens der Moment als die
Nationalmannschaft davon erfahren hat ja
ja
[Musik]
liegt nun doch ein Schatten über der
besten und saubersten WM aller Zeiten
wir wollen sie nicht hoffen immerhin hat
die EU dieses Jahr die Taxonomie
verabschiedet eine Art ja Katalog für
klimafreundliche Investitionen und
seitdem gelten sowohl Gas als auch
Atomkraft als nachhaltig herzlichen
Glückwunsch ja okay meine wenn das mit
dem Greenwashing so einfach ist frage
ich mich gerade warum hat die heute-show
eigentlich noch keinen
Nachhaltigkeitssiegel dazu lasse ich
mich jetzt mal professionell beraten von
Valerie Niehaus sie ist zertifizierter
nachhaltigkeitscoach Valerie was können
wir tun ja also erstmal stolz sein auf
das was hier schon nachhaltig läuft
nicht z.B dass diese Sendung seit fast
14 Jahren denselben Moderator hat
andere weniger nachhaltige Shows hätten
längst gesagt komm wir holen uns einen
neuen der alte verliert Haare
der fängt langsam an zu riechen
aber die heute-show sagt nein der
funktioniert noch der spricht ganze
Sätze der bleibt hier sitzen bis er zu
biomulch zerfällt also das schon mal
super okay nehme ich mal als Kompliment
ja also Luft nach oben sehe ich
allerdings beim Farbkonzept also jeder
Quadratzentimeter muss natürlich
zugeballert werden mit Bäumen
bächenbergen also dem ganzen Natur
Gedöns so
hinter ihm auch
viel besser merken Sie was die
studiolift wirkt direkt frischer
also am Ende doch alles nur Verpackung
was heißt hier nur Verpackung also
Verpackung ist alles auch die Zahncremes
von ekomie und Colgate versprechen
nachhaltige Verpackungen glatte
Augenwischerei weil es einfach nicht
sinnvoll ist eine Zahnpasta Tube noch
mal mit einem Karton zu versehen das ist
einfach völlig unnötig ja das ist
absolut nötig schauen Sie mal früher
haben die Idioten Zahnpasta einfach so
verkauft als nackte Tube wie in der
Steinzeit jetzt ist da ein Karton
drumherum auf dem steht
nachhaltige Verpackung so
und wenn ich diese Doppelpackung in
einem weiteren Karton packe wie
nachhaltig ist das denn bitte im Grunde
dreimal so nachhaltig ja so entsteht
aber auch dreimal so viel Abfall ja es
gibt ja unterschiedlichste Verfahren auf
dem Weg zur Nachhaltigkeit die Firma
Heidelberg Zement zum Beispiel hat sich
gedacht moment mal zement ist ja voll
scheiße fürs Klima so kann es also nicht
weitergehen das Unternehmen hat sich
gerade umbenannt von Heidelberg Zement
zu Heidelberg Materials Ausdruck für
mehr Nachhaltigkeit für den
klimaaktivisten ist das nicht
glaubwürdig
ja also den kann man es aber auch nicht
recht machen die deutschen
Verbraucherschützer wollen jetzt sogar
verbieten mit dem Slogan klimaneutrale
Produktion zu werben weil es die gar
nicht gibt ja sorry wenn Werbung sich
plötzlich an Fakten halten muss dann
können wir auch ganz aufhören ich kann
doch alles nicht wahr sein selbst der
Shell-Konzern macht in der Werbung einen
auf nachhaltig je mehr ich drüber
nachdenke ich will gar kein Ökosiegel
mehr
ich wollte ihn gerade eins verleihen
die heute-show wir recyceln seit 2009
gekauft vielen Dank
[Musik]
oh Gott der Dreh für die